Do any of you millennials remember the website Millsbury?
I haven't thought about it in years,
but I was in the grocery store the other day and all came back to me.
So if you were born in the nineties,
you probably played this as a middle schooler.
It was such a fun website.
It was so wholesome.
You would create your own little character
and then you would buy it like a house
and you could put clothes on them.
You could go buy clothes for them.
You would go to the grocery store,
get them their food,
and the foods were like all General Mills foods.
And so you kind of felt cool cause you knew the different foods.
Like when you go to the grocery store with your mom.
It was so much fun.
I spent so much time playing the baseball game on here
and the rope climbing game,
winning all these prizes and. Oh yeah,
you would do like, yard sales where you could sell your stuff to, like,
other people. And so I'm pretty sure you could have like,
a username and you could be friends with people you knew in real life.
I don't know. I need to go do some research.
But it was so much fun
and I kind of wish that they would bring it back.
It. Did anybody else play this?
I felt like it was huge at the time and then it just kind of went away.
But Anyway, lots of fun.
Very nostalgic.